to mark the release of the movie Steve
Jobs let's take a look at 7 things you
probably didn't know about danny boyle's
film on the co-founder of Apple although
the film is not a conventional biopic
screenwriter Aaron Sorkin script was
loosely based on Walter Isaacson's 2011
biography of Steve Jobs as well as
Sorkin's own interviews with key people
in jobs life but what really influenced
Sorkin script was talking to the Apple
co-founders first daughter Lisa who Jobs
originally denied with his even after a
paternity test proved otherwise Lisa
chose not to speak to Isaacson for her
father's biography but did give Sorkin a
real insight into her relationship with
her father which became an important
part of the film according to Kate
Winslet who plays former Macintosh
marketing chief Joanna Hoffman at the
table read Michael Fassbender who plays
Steve Jobs was the only actor who didn't
need his script in front of him and had
already nailed all of his lines however
before Fassbender landed the lead
Leonardo DiCaprio and Christian Bale had
both been contenders and according to
leaked emails initially Aaron Sorkin
wasn't keen on Fassbender playing the
part claiming he'd never heard of the
star of the x-men movies hunger and
inglorious basterds instead early on
Sorkin was keen to see Tom Cruise take
the role the way director Danny Boyle
approached filming Steve Jobs was rather
unusual compared to most feature films
first of all he made sure there was
plenty of time for rehearsals to help
the cast get comfortable with Aaron
Sorkin's fast-flowing dialogue driven
script the film is structured in three
parts or acts around the launches of the
Macintosh in 1984 the next in 1988 and
the iMac in 1998 so Boyle rehearsed and
then filmed each act separately rather
like a play with three weeks of
rehearsals before he shot act one and
two weeks of rehearsals before filming
act two and then again before act three
he also shot the whole film in sequence
which meant the actors could really get
into their characters in each of the
different periods of film covers each
act was shot in a different setting in
the San Francisco Bay Area
the 1984 Macintosh
which was shot in the Flint Center at
DeAnza Community College in Cupertino
which was the same location where the
real-life launch took place for the
launch of the next Danny Boyle filmed at
the San Francisco Opera House and he
wanted a location that reflected a
script sense of operatic revenge after
Jobs departed from Apple and to the iMac
launched Boyle chose to film at San
Francisco's Louise M Davies Symphony
Hall as he felt its futuristic look
suited that part of the film to capture
the spirit of each of the movies three
eras and locations cinematographer Allen
Kukla used different types of film he's
shot act one on 60 millimetres to get a
gritty and grainy look that reflected
the rough-edged feel of the early days
of the story for act 2 he wanted a
smooth filmic qualities of 35
millimetres in order to echo the story's
operatic themes while in the film's
third act he went through the digital
Alexa camera to match the high-tech feel
and clean designs of that stage and Jobs
his story on top of that because
director Danny Boyle wanted to give the
film a fluid feel and for the actors to
be able to move freely much of the film
was shot using a Steadicam a camera
stabilizer mount that's typically used
for action or chase scenes in
preparation for her role as Joanna
Hoffman Kate Winslet watched old footage
of Hoffman with jobs to get a feel for
her mannerisms and how she talked and
dressed Winslet also met with Hoffman
who even lent the production some of her
clothes from the era's the film depicts
in fact the production decided to give
Winslet an 80s asymmetrical hairstyle in
the movie as Hoffman told the actress
how she disliked symmetry so much that
she used to were just a single earring
or mismatched earrings composer Daniel
Pemberton took a different approach to
each of the film's acts essentially
creating three different scores to give
act 1 an electronic vibe Pemberton used
a variety of synthesizers that were
popular in 1984 including the yamaha
cs-80 which featured heavily in Vangelis
music and that was especially fitting as
jobs as a big Vangelis fan to reflect
the operatic feel of act 2
- Pemberton composed to score for a 74
piece classical orchestra and voices and
even wrote lyrics in Italian about
computers for the Opera chorus to sing
as for act 3 he produced most of the
music on a computer using Apple software
to create a more abstract sound design
now let me know in the comments below
what do you think of Steve Jobs and what
are your favorite biopics if you enjoyed
this video do please share it hit the
thumbs-up button and subscribe for more
things you didn't know as well as movie
reviews and interviews thanks for
watching yippee-ki-yay movie lovers